the jurgen experience i am yeah i mean
i'm
someone who's worked my legs out forever
like most of my life but i've never done
these exercises and part of me is like
how the [ __ ] did i not know about this
how am i finding out about this from
jamie
and then from instagram
i mean it's very simple it's very simple
how this occurs
so
i wasn't taught it either
and didn't get a scholarship to college
painting walls during the day i have
nothing i had no backup plan
so
i was like all right
i'm not going to make it as a basketball
player i'm just going to figure out how
to bulletproof my knees so then i start
really digging into the corners of the
earth to find data you see what i mean
right
everything we're talking about right now
in this podcast without question will be
in the textbooks in 20 30 years wow but
it takes a long time
for textbooks to change you see what i
mean so you're not going to find the
stuff we're talking about
in the main textbooks that people are
going to schooling and learning
so i find some pockets of information
work really hard on it
rejuvenate my knees managed to market
myself and get a college basketball
scholarship
played two years at a junior college you
know like in america we have these
two-year
juco
a lot a lot of wild stories had an
amazing coach there
and kept healing my knees while playing
so like i was improving as i was going
through my first two years of college
got a full ride d1 scholarship at age
23. wow so i went from mr 18 year old
on my butt oh you know like people from
my hometown
by the time i was 23 getting a d1
scholarship it was like what the heck is
going on so i actually had started
training kids in the summer just because
it was like this unbelievable thing that
had happened but
here's what i'm getting to
i go to this division one school
and
the strength coach who has his degrees
from college and everything he's not
going to let me
do my drills
the very things
that got me the scholarship
it's not a wild concept what did he say
you're not allowed to do your knees over
toe stuff here
so
the school gave me a scholarship
full ride i'm gonna be
you know living out my dream having a
chance to play in march madness whatever
now i mentioned i was 23. right so i get
a call from the head coach before the
season
and he tells me
nca has denied your eligibility they say
you're like your clock is up
none of us knew it's a very rare thing
i've never heard of this happening of
someone like
fixing their knees and then later going
to college
so we did a whole appeal process but in
the back of my mind i was like
i don't want to
now
have to go two years trying to train
behind the strength coach's back and
look at the system so it's like it's not
his fault he's just doing what he
learned in the textbook right how the
heck is the textbook gonna change you
see what i mean did you have a
conversation with him privately
um
anyone can relate if you've been in team
sports and you bring something up to
like the head strength coach or the head
coach or something like that
there's a lot of pressure like it's like
you're risking
getting in murky water having a bad
reputation on the team
so i never got past that
that opening conversation with him of
like
you know i've been doing these things so
did he see you doing it like how did
this happen yeah i told him which
exercise like these are the things i've
been doing that are like that have me
able to play because i couldn't play
before so
explain how the conversation takes place
so
i meet him he's going to be running my
program right and i say okay
i need to add in
these things like you've seen these
knees over toes split squats right very
uncommon exercise
no no you're not gonna be doing that
here so it's just a total stop
so i'm not gonna be doing
so he tells you can't do them no knees
over toast does he say why no it's no
knees over toes
in his gym
so i knew i was gonna have to be going
you know
just on my own time outside of school
and classes and workouts to keep up my
routines
so
when this whole thing went on with my
eligibility getting denied
um
i was request i was the head coach
thought i should get a lawyer i'd be
able to fight it but i actually just
withdrew from the thing and became a
trainer
so when he was saying this to you yep
did you try to argue it did you try to
say this is what's helped me this is
what got me here exactly and what did he
say
he's overtones did you show him some of
the literature did you show him some
poliquin stuff no i never got that far
but it was also for me being a new
recruit college kid it was like
that was a that was a an intimidating
moment for me you know what i mean yeah
i didn't have excellent communication
skills i was a nobody you know yeah i
was just a new request that sucks
yeah but
in his mind he's just enforcing
what he believes you know and what he
learned is the right thing to do exactly
he's literally a professional exactly
yeah so
new data can come out and new data has
even come out on full knee bend and your
knee going over toes and stuff like that
and how it actually leads to less pain
and more athleticism but now
from the moment that data comes out it's
not like the textbooks magically all
switch you know i mean
the whole curriculum and textbooks and
the tests and so even in my first couple
years of college i would have to be
guessing on tests like is the answer
the actual answer that's up to date
right now or is the answer
what the textbook thinks is the answer
does that make sense yeah
and it goes like that for diet and you
see like new data is constantly coming
out right yeah
so
that's why for me it's it's really
nothing
um
i'm not even trying to be critical
of that system there's so many cool
aspects to college and stuff like that
i just knew i had to create
an alternative yeah so i just it was
like a light bulb went off and i just
went hard core as a trainer from that
point i've
you know now when did you start getting
traction like when did people start
paying attention and recognize like hey
this guy is really on something
making results in person
so i had a gym for seven years
and i became known as the knee guy where
was your gym at clearwater florida it's
like a beach town by tampa store
in the city oh cool so
getting results in person became known
as like the knee guy
and quite honestly friends telling me
like you need to like
go on social media and stuff like that
so i hated social media at the time why
this was only a few years ago
i don't know what reasons could you come
up with
all of them exactly
so yeah
so
but i did realize okay i'm gonna need to
approach social media the same way i
approach needs and try to become as
competent as i can possibly be and be
patient with it and be responsible and
you know what i mean and so yeah i
really liked gary vee because he had a
positive vibe you know what i mean maybe
too positive
i'm just kidding
i really like garyvee because
it seemed like you could be yourself and
do it and actually win on social media
yeah and you're the same way you're just
you and you're winning
more than anyone that's you know another
conversation thanks for everything
you're doing you're
the voice for us right now so i don't
want to be
i i understand i understand i can't even
imagine but
there are examples you can just be you
you can just try to help people you
don't have to be perfect i can make as
many mistakes sure progress but tomorrow
i'm going to go out and i'm going to try
to help people and the next day i'm
going to go out i'm going to try to help
people yeah and that's how i'm going to
measure my life by how much i help
people there's no ego if i made a
mistake move on try to help people so
i've just been doing that since and i
did count up though for
you know if someone wanted to be
realistic about it if you're like me
you're from a small town you have no
special connections or anything
i answered over 500 000
messages oh my god
before
before i hit like 100 000 followers oh
my god so i'm at like
so
how do you have the time for that
um do you give yourself like a a
like an allocation i'm very organized i
also
have gone multiple years of my life
without any entertainment sources
whatsoever it's like this past year 2021
i did no tv no netflix no video games
not a single sports game of any kind oh
my god yeah
so that sounds monastic well i can
i don't consider myself a lucky person
so i had to go okay
i know how much this dragging this
freaking sled works right and it gets
your cardio in and you can put older
people on it you can rehab on it but
people aren't aware of it the way i am
how do i get there okay i want to get
lucky i want my post to do well i want
people to
know what i know yeah so i tried to put
luck on my side and and literally work
at it harder than anyone else was gonna
work at putting you know
uh
the negatives out there here's this
empowering positive thing i'm trying to
get out
went hard at it